want to be happy build a life not just
the business hey it's evan carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you've got michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best belief life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only robin sharma
i believe your happiest not when you're
watching tv you're not happiest when
you're playing with your apps you're not
happiest when you're looking for likes
you're not happiest when you're fooling
around
you're happiest when you're growing
i think we're hardwired that it's a
survival mechanism
we're happiest when we're making
progress so we have a deep fear of
self-betrayal and when we when we don't
capitalize on our
talents
what starts to happen
is that what starts to happen is that
we start to lose energy we lose
creativity and we lose productivity i
believe that
many of us the reason we don't have
energy the reason why we're not as
creative as we want the reason why we're
not as productive as we want is because
we have betrayed our talent and the deep
wise primal hero within knows of that
self-betrayal
and we start to hate ourselves is that
interesting point show of hands
the place of knowing within you knows
that you've betrayed your talents
and we start to hate ourselves
and so we have a deep well of
self-loathing inside of us
that actually minimizes the four
interior empires and the four interior
empires are the gateway into the
exterior empires of creativity
productivity performance prosperity
lifestyle and impact how do you get to
creativity productivity
prosperity
performance
lifestyle and impact
through the four interior empires
mindset heartset healthset and soulset
so that first fear is important
second fear fear of standing out well
how are you going to innovate if you
haven't worked through your fear this is
why personal mastery is the gateway into
it's the gateway it's the gateway drug
in the world class let's start from
within often we wait for more heroes and
we wait for
leaders to show us the way when deep in
our hearts we know the way
and we know that by standing steadfast
around our ideals by
pursuing our mighty missions which make
us happy
by
expressing our genius and our glory
that we have within us and by standing
for honesty and truth and dignity and
love for all
we lead the world in our own unique way
and so please don't give away your power
to the economy don't give away your
power to the pandemic don't give away
your power to the disruption don't give
away your power to the trolls that are
out there
i mean i'm seeing so many people they're
unhappy and so what they try to do is
they try to take other people
down
because they're angry and what i'm
suggesting to you is be a light in the
world christopher morally said we can
curse the darkness or we can be a light
and i think
you know
hatred doesn't bring love into the world
to state the obvious
so also use this volatility of the
planet right now
to grow in your creativity
what i find is when things are very
uncertain i become more vulnerable
and when i become more vulnerable i
become more intimate with my creativity
so i want you to think about that how
you can produce your magnum opus how you
can produce your tour de force how you
can write that book you've always wanted
to write or launch that movement you've
always wanted to launch
by exploiting any fear or insecurity
that you're in
for a greater purpose
along with creativity productivity we
are at a war
and we are to war against diversion and
trivial amusements and distractions
and you know one of the keys i'm writing
a lot about it in the new book
is
a key element of genius your genius is
isolation you've got to get away from
the world to do your greatest work
when i was a young lawyer i worked with
a lawyer who used to book a hotel room
in the city we lived in
when he'd be working on a big trial
and he just locked the door put d do not
disturb on the phone order room service
just to isolate himself to get into his
state of deep flow
and i know i do my best work when i'm
away from the world and i turn off my
phone for days
and i don't check any notifications and
i'm literally lost to the world
and that's why i think so many artists
live by the sea and so many artists
you know
isolate themselves in a little cabin
i think of andrew wyeth i think of jd
salinger
you know these people had these
cottages where they would go and work
for hours so they could
experience transient hypo frontality
which i've written about in the 5 a.m
club you can learn about it it's really
the key to genius and you need to know
it if you want to bring your genius to
the world
anyway
remember that the key to productivity is
isolation
and then i think the final few things i
i would share to navigate this world
that we're in
would be
you know kindness is so important
and that involves the basics that are
often not
so obvious
saying please and thank you
please means i appreciate you thank you
means i respect you
being on time which is
the trait of royalty i think punctuality
is the trait of royalty in many ways
and
just communicating in a way that's
respectful you can say whatever you want
so long as you communicate it with
respect sometimes
i see people online they say i disagree
with you
look disagreement is absolutely fine but
why do you have to say it like that
just say here's another way to look at
it here's how i look at it
communicating in a
adversarial or antagonistic way doesn't
serve anyone
and i think what the world needs right
now is more respect
more kindness
and more gentleness
final thing i would say is make sure you
have some fun you know even
in dark times and uncertain times there
are still
ways we can find gratitude we can walk
listen to the birds song i was reading
about
um
with all the lockdowns there's a
a city in india that finally is able to
see the himalayas after 10 years
because there's so much less pollution
now
so look for things to be grateful for
you know the bird song
a sunrise a beautiful piece of poetry a
great sonata or other piece of music the
laugh of your child a beautiful
home-cooked meal but make sure you find
some time to experience the simple
graces every single day because um
you know you'll find them if you look
for them i hear that a lot like where do
i start i would say there is huge power
in beginning there's huge power
in starting it's almost like the
universe begins to support you when you
take that first step yes i would say
believe in you when no one else believes
in you until the whole world believes in
you i think the reason why we even have
the question
of where do i begin it's from fear
we're paralyzed
so it's start to believe in yourself and
start to read books and realize all the
great heroes
were anonymous for 25 or 30 years before
the world celebrated them
um i would also say
genius is less about genetics and more
about your habits so you know start with
the philosophy of beginning and starting
start to believe in yourself understand
that
you're going to be laughed at you're
going to be misunderstood and every
great hero is misunderstood at the
beginning but then install the right
habits and this is where the this is
where the methodology does follow the
philosophy
once you get the philosophy which is
just the truth what do you want your
life to stand for
what's most important to you what are
your big five for the rest of your life
what are the key values and beliefs you
want to live by once you get the
philosophy
calibrated and you don't follow the
world's philosophy you have the bravery
and wisdom to trust what feels right to
you
then start installing the habits that
science have proven to work and for me
it's been the 5 a.m club is very
powerful the five great hours rule the
second wind workout which is basically
if you believe exercise is valuable why
would you only do it once a day
the
micro bravery a great pre-sleep workout
the weekly design system etc it's easier
to behave yourself into a new way of
thinking than think yourself into a new
way of acting
so act first
and then you'll start to think and
believe it as opposed to think and
believe and then start acting practice
being spectacular long enough that
unspectacular
unspectacularity
has no ability to enter your orbit
right i mean how do you how does
discipline is a muscle you are under
someone's undisciplined and then you get
out of the bed and you get up early or
you make your bed or you do 25 push-ups
or whatever
and you do it and you do it and you do
it through the power of
neuroplasticity the malleability of the
human brain it's almost like a metaphor
is for anyone who wants to make a change
who says i can't do it well your can't
do it is the reason why you're not doing
it
because they can't do it
is your weaker self versus your heroic
self
so
it's almost like a metaphor you wake up
in the morning you know and you want to
do something
let's say it's to be a better more
focused better performer because an
addiction and distraction is the depth
of your creative production
so it's almost like a wide open mountain
meadow
and the first time you practice turning
off your phone and practicing what i
call in the everyday hero manifesto the
five great hours rule forget working
more than five great hours a day
five sweaty intense hours so say you
want to practice that it's almost like
you're walking in a mountain meadow
and it's a pure mountain meadow you do
it after a few weeks now the meadow
becomes a trail because you've practiced
it eventually the trail
becomes a road and you keep on
practicing it and eventually the road
becomes a highway and if you keep on
practicing it the highway becomes a
super highway and then if you look at
the neurobiology you've got this circuit
and around it is my starts to form a
fatty tissue called myelin and some
people believe some neuroscientists
believe that myelin is the secret of
genius that's why wayne gretzky could
send the puck to where it was going
versus where it was that's why steve
jobs could see around corners and he was
this favorite word i love prescient he
could see where everything was going
before anyone else could
it's not because these people are cut
from a different cloth it's because they
run different protocols think different
thoughts and they do different things
and what i'd say to wrap that up is
to have the results only five percent of
the population has we've got to be
willing
to be brave enough and faithful enough
to do what only
what 95 percent of the population are
unwilling to do
it is such a great pull
when you start to move to higher grades
of victory
to
stop doing the very things that made you
successful to stop learning to stop
going to art galleries to stop having a
mentor to stop getting up early to stop
taking care of your health set to stop
polishing your beliefs it is so easy to
fall in love with success and that's why
being successful is actually very
dangerous because you might stop doing
the very things that brought your magic
to the world so the fifth element of
this deconstruction if you want to
continually be upgrading your
performances
is to never lose that white belt
mentality never think you're a master
actually one thing about masters
they never think they are masters and
the moment you think you are a master
the moment you think you're the most
important person in every room that
you're in the moment that your ego
screams more loudly than your hunger to
grow and represent mastery is the
beginning of your descent into
obsolescence and irrelevance anyone who
is not living
at absolute world class
you are your own worst enemy
but because it's so subconscious if you
haven't done the deep inner work we
blame it on oh it's the supplier oh it's
the market is contracting oh it's a hard
time in the global economy the reality
is there are people out there at every
possible domain of wealth who are doing
amazing things if you're not living your
dream life or at your absolute best
it's because you're in your own way and
what is the solution it's working not
just on mindset like so many people are
talking about
mindset heart set health set
soul set
and
getting that you know acupuncture might
be the way to do it plus hypnotherapy
could be doing it and could be massage
and it could all that inner work that a
lot of people go oh that's not for me
well that's how you move through the
blocks of your shadows that are covering
your primal genius there's a concept i
teach marie called the five great hours
concept you see
this oh 12 hour work day or eight hour
work day comes from the industrial era
where the more we work the more tires we
could make or more cars we could produce
but we're cognitive workers now we're
creative workers you know our ideas are
the currency of our success right now
five great hours is simply this i
believe that you don't need to work any
more than five great hours every day
because just think about it if you know
how to set up your ecosystem if you
created what i call that tight bubble of
total focus have you worked with without
your phone if you use some of the ideas
that are in the book
basically your five hours would be
equivalent to most people's 12 hours or
even a few days of work and so i teach
people work from eight o'clock till two
o'clock and then at two o'clock go to an
art gallery go get a massage go get on
your mountain bike i mean five
incredibly powerful hours every day you
don't need to work any more than that
most people on the planet today are not
living in the present they're certainly
not living in the future they are stuck
in the resentments the bitterness the
pain the frustration
the disappointments of the past
you know there are so many people on the
planet and they're really operating from
the past and here's what i mean
something happened to them when they
were little kids
they were told not to dream too big
they were told to dress like everyone
else
they had a dream and the dream failed
they
or maybe you were a teenager
and there was someone that you loved and
you got rejected or maybe you were 22
and you started a business and you
failed in that business
and now it's
10 years later or 20 years later or 40
years later
and you're still living in the past
i want you to really think about this
you know most people on the planet today
are not living in the present they're
certainly not living in the future they
are stuck in the resentments the
bitterness the pain the frustration
the disappointments of the past and it
could be a month ago it could be 20 or
30 years ago and if you don't work
through what happened in your past you
are resigned to spend the rest of your
future stuck in the past
if you want to play it mastery in your
craft you want to play it mastery in
your thinking you want to play it
mastery in your performance you want to
play it mastery in your income you want
to play it mastery in your service to
humanity you owe it to yourself and the
best within you and the talent that
resides within you
to do the work required to let go of the
past
i don't know what it's going to look
like for you it could be meditation it
could be journaling could be prayer it
could be working with a healer could be
working with a mentor could be
affirmations it could be visualization
it could be reading the books of the a
players so that their thinking infuses
and hypnotizes and recodes your
neurobiology
but you owe it to yourself to release
the past
so you can free yourself from the things
that happened that disappointed you and
move into a bold and brilliant and
gorgeous future
please do not let
a stained past
deny
your spotless future creativity oh
creativity is so important for every
single one of us when we were little
kids you know
we had such creativity in us creativity
is not just for poets and dancers and
writers and filmmakers
creativity is the birthright and the
hallmark of have every human being with
a beating heart today
and so
if you're not feeling creative if you're
not downloading amazing ideas that are
allowing you to disrupt your field and
own your game and make the world a
better place it's not because you don't
have genius in you it's because you've
masked or blocked your access to that
genius in the circle of legends the
model that i teach that has been
revolutionary to my clients is the
genius betrayal
process
and it really speaks to a number of
influences that act on us after the
moment that we're born it makes me think
of what picasso said he said it took me
four years to paint look like monet and
it took me a lifetime had to remember to
paint like a child
and so what happens is after we're born
we are influenced
subconsciously by our parents who teach
us
as best as they know how the world works
we're influenced by our peers we're
influenced by our teachers we're
influenced as we get older by the media
around us we're influenced by the
cultural
beliefs that are entrenched in the
nation that we lived in or that we live
in of course
and so what happens is subconsciously
incrementally every single day we
receive this messaging and this
languaging that
takes us away from who we truly are and
we lose our native creativity and our
curiosity a little kid is always saying
why why why
but sometimes that curiosity gets
stuffed out of us by people saying stop
asking so many questions and by the
messaging of the media and the culture
saying stop asking so many questions
don't dream like you that you can be an
astronaut and an empire maker and a
startup entrepreneur or a great teacher
or frontline worker play in a box think
small and after a while
year after year after a year we start to
think small we start to betray our
genius we start to give up on who we are
and we forget who we truly are in many
ways the process of self-mastery is not
transformation it's remembering
a human life is a short ride
now is that something that's depressing
no it actually something that can be
inspiring and activating in the most
positive way of ways once we know that
our days are numbered whether we live
for 100 more years or one more year
it reminds us that we must not hold back
on expressing our primal genius we must
not hold back on doing what feels most
right to our hearts
our characters and our souls
for fear of rejection or being laughed
at by the
chattering crowd you and i must realize
the potential and the gifts and the
talents we've been blessed with not only
to live these soaring lives that destiny
wants for us but for the benefit of a
better world there's a little bit of
wind where i am so forgive me and i
think we're gonna be okay
usefulness i wrote a book
22 years ago called who will cry when
you die which was all about legacy
before legacy became a popular
thing to contemplate
and i think ultimately life is a short
ride and i think ultimately you do want
to think about
how you'll have impact on the world
because even a long life is
a temporary ride
and i think when you look at people who
are on their final stages of their life
they don't wish they had more money
more fame and they don't wish they had
bigger houses and they don't wish they
had bigger titles and they don't wish
they had
whatever you want to fill into that
blank that i'm
figuratively speaking just put in there
for you
no at the end of our lives we all have
the same human longings at the end
and these are things like greater
connection with those we loved
we wish that we had walked the earth
more lightly
we wish that we had been kinder
and we wished
more helpful to our neighbors on the
dreamer's journey there's a key word
that i invite you to consider and it's
called faith and you know what faith
means but
you have probably at the front end of
this year
developed a series of goals and high
value targets and your personal mount
everest
and then there's that lag time between
the fulfillment of your desires
and waiting for them to come true that's
a period where often we feel frustration
and we actually feel doubt
will my dreams come true will i make
them true why is it taking so long
and that's where we get to do a faith
walk we get to
say we've done our best now let life do
the rest and we have to trust that
things will unfold at the time
that is best for them to unfold the
universe really does
have our back and
when we don't get we want what we want
on the timeline that we expect please
trust and know
it's because you are being protected and
something even better is coming
psychologists will tell you that your
daily behavior always reflects your
deepest beliefs i'm going to say that
again because it's so important your
daily behavior always reflects your
deepest beliefs
our daily behavior what we do every day
of our life
it always is in alignment with our story
of how we see ourselves in the world
most of us we have been born into
brilliance and resigned into average
because from the moment we've been born
we pick up these beliefs from the people
who
raise us our teachers our peers media
society and so all of those messages
intellectually and emotionally that we
pick up through what we learn and what
we experience micro and macro trauma it
starts to contract us
when we when we are first born we're
possibilitarians we little kids want to
be astronauts and they want to be
firefighters they want to be
billionaires they want to be inventors
and then they you know 40 50 years old
they've been contracted
and brainwashed and heartwashed into
forgetting
their their promise and their potential
i know your show so much about people's
promise and their potential
so
the first part is working on your story
and reverse hypnotizing yourself and we
can talk in the the everyday here
manifesto has hundreds of tools to help
you do that
second word i said was practice most
people they go to the gym to practice
they want to be a better skier i i know
where you're from you know there's great
skiing
well
all changes hard at first messing the
middle beautiful at the end
right so just start practicing the new
skill it'll be hard at first to be messy
in the middle it'll be beautiful at the
end it's processed process people
understand that for skiing they
understand that for chess they
understand that for any skill but when
it comes to personal mastery
they want it in an instant or they have
a belief that it doesn't even work so
practice we have a gift a human gift
it's called neuroplasticity
we all can transform
we're built to grow but we try it for a
few days we listen to a podcast like
this and we don't stay with the process
university college london says it takes
66 days of daily practice to wire in a
new habit until it becomes automatic
most people won't stay with it for 66
days but i think that idea
if you stay with it for 66 days is
powerful now people go oh
i better stay with it for past a week
third word i used is consistency
what you do every day is so much more
powerful that than what you do once a
year
so re start rewiring your story and your
philosophy
and then start
practicing
like any other skill make personal
mastery practice and that's why the 5m
club is a global movement it's an
institutionalized morning practice to
work on yourself while the rest of the
world is sleeping and then finally
um
consistency i do want to mention one
thing because there are a lot of
messages in personal development that
are so
you know they're so often said they
almost sound boring and ubiquitous
and like you know chase your fear is
certainly one of those but i do want to
mention the everyday hero manifesto is
it's a very disruptive book and it's a
very contrarian book it's it's not it's
i've been in this field for 26 years
and
the book is like it's full of models
that you really won't see anywhere else
like one if i can pull it out but like
it's called the troll deconstruction
where i've actually
deconstructed how to transcend tr why
truck trolls do what they do
there it's so it's like a whole
deconstruction there's a deconstruction
on the titans decline my work with
fortune 5
fortune 100 companies i
deconstructed why great companies fall
apart there's there's a lot in the book
that is very
contrarian for example even everyone's
talking about mindset i talk about the
four interior empires mindsets only one
of them uh everyone's talking about
hustle and grind i if you look at the
science hustle and grind actually
doesn't make you more productive
working in cycles of intense performance
and recovery so i just wanted to make
that point that you know the book is a
very fresh book and i'm really excited
to bring it to people we all want to be
satisfied we all want to be happy we all
want to wake up every day and go through
life feeling a sense of joy but there is
a great danger in being completely
satisfied when i work with the
billionaires and the titans of industry
and the hollywood superstars here's what
i notice they're never satisfied now
sometimes if you don't manage
that unsatisfaction
you're going to be a very unhappy person
i'm just reporting on reality a lot of
the true titans it's never enough they
are always dissatisfied they always want
to work their craft better they always
want to have more influence they always
want to have greater impact they always
want to grow their movement so just
remember that first element of this
deconstruction satisfaction breeds
stagnation you want to
be joyful and grateful and yet at the
same time you never want to lose the
fire in your belly to be better to
materialize more of your primal genius
to offer value to more people and to
grow the very thing that you do i think
the world has
taught us that a hero is a nelson
mandela a mother teresa rosa parks a
hedy lamarr an albert einstein a ludwig
van beethoven
and sure those people are great heroes
they influence millions and millions of
people but what about the baker who
rises at 4 30 in the morning and does
their work like picasso painted what
about the single mother or father
you know working as a gardener long
hours trying to put food on the table
what about the in this world we live in
the front line workers who risk
themselves to serve their communities
what about the teachers what about the
poets
who
are toiling in anonymity for 20 years
pursuing their vision and their craft
when no one really understands them
but they do it because it's the
they want to put honest work out into
the world and so i wrote the everyday
hero manifesto jeff
it's part
handbook for exponential productivity
it's part manual for living a
world-class life and it's part
instruction book for being a spiritual
heavyweight on this planet that needs
real heroes and what i'm trying to do is
remind
people that you don't you you have
heroism in you
we've been programmed out of
believing our heroism we haven't been
taught the tools that allow us to
exploit and express our
heroism but just because we don't think
of ourselves often as heroes doesn't
mean we are not
meant for heroism and can't be heroic
so what how would you define hero
in this sense
well the book is like there's so many
different ideas i mean someone who
pushes masterwork into the marketplace
where there's so much mediocrity
definitely heroic someone who
is honest in a room of thieves
is heroic
someone who
has a vision for their future and what i
call a mighty mission and then
progressively moves towards living it
even if there are trolls and haters and
cynics is a hero someone who is
something as simple as you know you're
at a bus stop or you're at a train
when you see someone in need i was just
doing a little traveling
you know someone needs help lifting
their bags onto the train you just you
just do it or you see someone you have
on an airplane you lift up their luggage
into the overhead compartment because
you think it's a polite thing to do i
mean that's a small act of heroism how
about leaning into your fears we all
have these fears most people run away
from them there's a chapter in the book
called hugging your monster
and there's a story you know there's
this grand master he's walking up this
mountain and he's leading his followers
and they're going to this great
monastery
and once they eventually arrive at the
monastery jeff they see there's these
three chained dogs outside of the
monastery
and the other people grow a little bit
you know timid and then eventually the
dogs break free from the chains and they
start running towards the group
the other people start running away but
the master does something interesting he
starts running towards directly towards
the dogs the dogs get even more excited
and even more violent they started
running even more quickly towards the
master the master yawns and he laughs
and he starts running even more quickly
towards the dogs
eventually the dogs get scared of this
master and they run away
and they retreat and the master yawns
again and walks into the into the
monastery
it's a very simple metaphor but most
people what do we do when the barking
dogs if our thieves if our fears run
towards us
we run away but doubts are liars and
fears are thieves
and so
running towards our fears and hugging
our monsters and doing the things that
frighten us that's actually how we get
our power back every time you do
something you are frightened to do
you take the power you gave to the thing
you were frightened to do back and if
you do it methodically consistency daily
you eventually move toward fearlessness
that's heroic there's such power
in personal improvement i saw a comment
section of an online newspaper and
someone was mocking
the idea of self-improvement but
michelangelo's david in florence
beethoven's moonlight sonata
jonas salks vaccine
the ceiling of the sistine chapel
da vinci's mona lisa the taj mahal
those were all examples
of self-improvement
our civilization has got to where it's
at right now through the progress of
people who improve themselves by
reaching deep within themselves
and saying i am more than i currently am
and i have a vision
and i will materialize it when it's easy
when it's hard when it's dark when
there's sunshine when i'm doubtful when
i'm confident
so the second word representing the
second piece of advice i'd give if i was
dying let's say would be grow use each
day as a platform to build your
knowledge base so you can deliver more
value use each day to grow in your
self-awareness use each day to grow your
muscles and your physicality use each
day to read and pray and meditate and
journal
so you grow into your and glorify your
greatness what makes legendary is
longevity
the i once had a client who did a course
at harvard business school and he said
the professor kept on reminding us or
asking us is it sustainable is it
sustainable is it sustainable so
the first thing that anyone wants to
build a world-class company needs to
think about is you know how can we play
for the absolute long run and sustain
our success it's hard enough to get to
world class but what makes the legends
is they sustain world class an nba
superstar it's great to get an nba world
championship the legends sustain it for
seven years or ten years like a michael
jordan or look at someone like a kobe
bryant who had such a long career so you
want to think about
tom brady retired i mean 20 brilliant
four years or something crazy
brilliant example and i think
one of the things that allows the
company first of all we can deconstruct
the whole thing you've got to be
different you know so many companies are
copying what everyone else
is doing because they don't have the
bravery to be unique what you want to do
is you want we are paid as entrepreneurs
and leaders to push mass magic into the
marketplace if you're not pushing
outright magic every day here a
manifesto 16 months of obsession in the
pandemic is how i wrote it i wanted
every line perfect we are paid not to
push push mediocrity and i think that's
what the culture sells us it's better to
push a thousand mediocrities than a
piece of magic into the marketplace is
what the culture says so you've got all
these entrepreneurs
pushing out work books code everything
every day
take four years and i'm just giving a
metaphor but michelangelo spent four
years
handcrafting the ceiling of the sistine
chapel
taj mahal took 22 years
you know even one thing that apple uh
that um steve jobs learned at pixar
four
years for every movie
and he after he came back to apple
he brought that philosophy four years
for the imac
four years
and then the ipod came out
so one thing be absolutely different
raise your standards to push magic into
the marketplace because you we are paid
to push out product that stuns people
with with their value
why else do
companies fail
they get more interested in in buying
getting their name on monuments than
building the great companies
there's a a slave
the the roman military commander called
the dukes had a slave and the slaves job
was to whisper in his ear memento homo
memento
remember you're just a man
and what i've seen with so many i've
mentored many billionaires one of the
biggest snares they fall into is the
world loves them the world adores them
they actually start to believe it
i i know we don't have time to get into
the whole deconstruction on the titans
decline but what start one of the
biggest traps people fall into is they
forget that it is your customers
who you serve these are the people who
put food onto your table so keep on
becoming obsessed with how many how may
i deliver more value
to these people that than they have any
right to receive
and keep on innovating inventing getting
hungry getting getting even better being
meticulous if not impeccable
around promise keeping is a great
way to increase your self-discipline and
your willpower and your character and
your spirituality
if you say to someone you will call them
next week to take them for lunch
do it you say to someone you're reading
an amazing new book you've heard about
it it's called the everyday hero
manifesto or any book of course
and you say you'll send it to them
because you love it so much
do it
and as you become meticulous and
outright impeccable with keeping your
promises
you get to a place where you simply
cannot not
follow through in your promises and it
builds such credibility in other
people's eyes but it really gives you
this iron will
even if you say you're gonna do a
workout so yourself promises follow
through on those the more you follow
through on self promises the stronger
your willpower gets remember it's like a
muscle
the more you use it the more you
exercise it the stronger it will become
i believe there are actually three other
interior empires that complete some
personal heroism equation
mindset is it important absolutely
because that's your psychology your
daily behavior reflects your deepest
beliefs unless you upgrade your
psychology
then your behavior will always be
limited and no question positive
thinking is important but i there's a
chapter in the book called the big lie
of positive thinking yes
but yeah so your mindset's important
having said that there are three other
interior empires the second is your
heart set
now this a lot of people i know so many
entrepreneurs and industry titans and
professional sports superstars follow
your work this could sound like
a little flaky and weak actually it's
incredibly powerful to purify your heart
set because your mindset is your
psychology your heart set is your
emotionality yeah we are as human beings
we have emotions
it was a wide open heart that allowed
beethoven to do the moonlight sonata it
was a wide open heart that allowed
shakespeare to do his work or hedy
lamarr to invent if you look at the most
successful even industry titans these
people are being driven by a compelling
cause steve jobs did what he did not
because he cared about money steve jobs
did what he did because he was an artist
who wanted to bring great beauty to the
world i heard an interview yesterday on
tributes after his death
from people who knew him and they said
he would he was yes he would get angry
because he was so invested in his mighty
mission
in making the world a better place he
was almost evangelical
evangelical there was there was one
thing i found this so fascinating he
called one of his designers two in the
morning when they're working on the
iphone
designer wakes up yes steve
he says um steve jobs says well you know
in the back of the iphone there's three
screws
designer says but that's inside no one's
ever gonna see those don't worry steve
steve jobs says yes but we know those
three screws are there
and two screws are going to be much
better
fix it
so so heart set
is
our up our higher level emotions like
gratitude awe and wonder
and yet here is the key point our heart
set also is all the suppressed emotions
that we pick up as we go through life
carl jung called it the shadow side
sigmund freud said all of the suppressed
emotions that we do not feel like guilt
anger shame disappointment frustration
that we pick up as we go through life if
those are not dealt with
they come back in ugly ways
and so and they're suppressants to your
genius well that's that is the absolute
key because if our society doesn't
welcome us to work through those
so what it creates is in the book i call
it a field of hurt
and so you can do go to all the
productivity courses you can read all
the business books you can learn exactly
what to do about mindset
but you're never going to get to world
class here or greatness because there
will always be a block between who you
are and who you truly are because of all
of those suppressed emotions once you
learn how to release them
you get intimate with your inner heroism
you your creativity source your
productivity source you actually open
your heart to love great products are
made of love great teams are built of
love great movements are launched from
love then there's so there's mindset
there's heart set there's health set and
then there's soul set soul set is your
spirituality i'm not necessarily talking
about religion
but once you turn down the loud voices
of your ego
we can talk about the tools to do it but
and you start to hear the silent
whispers of your inner hero
you start living the truth
and when you do that consistently you
become the most powerful person in every
room that you're in
and you don't need to worry about
branding
because your character and your energy
and your love
is the messenger for every single thing
you do there are only two reasons why we
are alive and i think if we strip away
the
accessories and the trinkets that the
world sells to us as the metrics of
success like how many social media likes
do you have how much money do you have
how much fame
in the book i say ff
jpf is always more valuable than ffa
joy peace and freedom is a million times
more valuable than fame fortune and
applies and ask anyone who has fame
fortune and applies
[Music]
what they would be willing to give
for joy
peace
and freedom
so
we get to live the great thing about
being human is we get to live as we wish
and i'm in no position to judge how
anyone's living personally i believe
when we get to the last hour for our
last day and we strip away all the
things people are so many people are
chasing
i
deeply believe only two things will
matter
number one
who did you become
as compared to our promise
how much of it did we materialize
through the work we're talking about
and number two how many people did we
help yeah
i mean
you know to me it's like
and and they're connected because the
more you own your truth and move through
the layers of fear doubt disbelief into
your most creative productive powerful
loving decent noble self the more you
will start to see yourself as an
instrument of service to the world i
think that's our fundamental nature it's
to give leave the safe harbor of the
known
because it's the most dangerous place to
be hug your monsters embrace your
dragons you will realize you have been
limiting your life based on a series of
illusions that were taught to you and
programmed into you and that were
brainwashed and heart washed against
your genius
invent
go blue ocean versus stay in the safe
harbor of the known
ask yourself what product service
magic can i bring to the marketplace
that no one else is daring to do don't
copy create
invent
and invent your life
once you are at a place where you know
all the answers to your biggest
questions tear it all down
reinvent yourself move to a new country
start reading new books try a new
business become a new person
invent is what i would say never stop
improving that acronym i've been
teaching nsi never stop improving
maintain that white belt mentality
the thing about a master is she never
thinks she's a master she always
operates like a beginner final the fifth
word i would offer to you with great
love respect and faith in your
brilliance mindset without heart set is
an empty victory but then there's two
more emotional interior empires the four
interior empires
mindset plus heart set
plus health set
right vitality
like i said the hunters on the savannahs
understood they didn't understand but
the way the brain developed
was literally
if you move your natural wiring in your
brain and physiology kicks into gear
you actually bdnf promotes neurogenesis
you create more brain cells dopamine
gets released norepinephrine serotonin
you feel happier you feel less stress
bdnf repairs damaged brain cells your
processing
heightens
you actually dial in your focus
unbelievable
the benefits of exercise but it's not
and here's another key idea on the third
interior empire
health set
vitality is the dna of legendary
you cannot put a price tag on getting
into the greatest fitness of your life
and then some of you and i'm going to
work on you with great love and respect
are going to say but if i hire a massage
therapist and if i get a physical
trainer and if i get into acupuncture
and if i biohack and if i get my genome
tested to figure out my telomere so i
know my real age if i do all the things
that james
and greg are going to talk about it's
going to cost me a lot of money how many
people hear that or think that right now
be honest
fantastic here's a little insight just
because i love you i might not know you
but i feel love for you i'm here to
serve you i've got your back
[Music]
getting into world-class fitness will
cost you a lot of money
death will cost you more being braver of
finding ways to get braver and i don't
know it was one of those where you're
kind of like trying to guess what the
person is going to say and i was so
struck by that one
how do we practice getting braver what
does it mean to be braver and then how
does that end up being useful for us
what terrifies you most go directly
there
because discomfort is simply
growth in wolf's clothing
um
well yeah i mean the last chapter
is uh i don't want to give too much away
but it's it's um an experience i live
you know it's it's nelson mandela's
prison cell
have you been to robin island i haven't
but i am beyond obsessed with nelson
mandela so i know the story very well
you know i i i'd encourage you to go
because
standing that in that cell
feeling
the sensations will transform you at a
soul level as well as hard set levels so
how do we become more brave well
i went over to
nelson mandela's prison cell and i stood
there and i was shocked he didn't even
have a bed and he was in there for 18
years
then
i went over to the limestone quarry
and i saw where nelson mandela spent 10
years chipping away at stone to break
his spirit because they threw the stones
away
and then i saw the showers where this
elderly statesman would shower while the
young guards would laugh at him
and then in the book i talked about a
true fact where
he was asked on robben island to dig a
grave and he he
got in the grave
thinking he was going to die and the
prison guards urinated on
and my point is simply this when nelson
mandela was released from prison after
27 years of total incarceration
the he invited the prosecutor who was
seeking the death penalty to dinner
and he invited the prison guard who kept
him in prison for 18 years on robben
island
to his inauguration as president of
south africa and he was asked
why would you do that he said because
if i didn't i'd still be in prison
and my point is to lead and to become a
great hero
or an everyday hero
the doorway is through embracing our
suffering and doing difficult things i
think pleasure
has been promoted too much in our
society like no great
tight enough industry no legendary
cellist
no
great athlete you know the great ones
all understand that suffering is the
price
of greatness so
how do we become braver you you do the
difficult things that you don't feel
like doing but you know have the payoff
there is a reason many of the great
women and men of the world the great
history makers the great poets the great
philosophers the great
movement makers rose before the sun
there is a magic in the air at 5 a.m and
that's why the 5am club is so
transformational because it's the time
of greatest quietude and i believe
tranquility is the new luxury on our
planet it is a time of intimate
creativity because you've just been
rested your brain is fresh there's
there's latest uh there's there's very
recent cutting edge science coming out
now when you sleep your brain actually
has a mechanism to wash itself when you
wake up in the morning your willpower is
strongest when you wake up in the
morning you've got a full well of mental
focus and we know that focus in our
world is even more valuable than
intelligence and i could go on and on on
the benefits i mean you get up at 5 a.m
you've got the world to yourself there's
no crowds you can think you can plan you
can care for yourself in a world where
so many people are so depleted and so
the fi it the 5 a.m club really is a
game changer and then it's not just get
up at 5am and you know scratch your
stomach or stir up at the ceiling or
look at your phone or look at especially
not i believe you can play with your
phone or change the world you don't get
to do both yeah and so uh it the 5am
club method is based on the 20 20 20
formula i'm happy to get into it but
that is yeah tell us what it is that's
the revolutionizer and and it started
from my experience with working with
many billionaires i i've coached many of
the most successful financiers and
titans of industry for for over two
decades
and one of the things i would run them
through is the way you begin your day
sets up the way you live your day and so
the 20 20 20 formula that the book is
based upon is pretty simple i i go into
great detail in the book but
essentially it's from 5 to 5 20 the
first pocket is move
and i'm a fanatic about neuroscience and
why do you get up and move because
you're going to release serotonin which
is going to make you feel better you're
going to release dopamine which is the
pleasure and inspirational
neurotransmitter you're going to release
norepinephrine which will boost your
focus you'll promote neurogenesis marie
you can actually grow new brain cells
you'll increase your metabolic rate so
the way you beg the way you feel when
you first wake up is not the way you're
going to feel at 5 20. second pocket of
the 20 20 20 formula 20 minutes from 5
20 to 5 40 that's on reflection so a lot
of us are busy but what's the point of
being busy if you're doing the wrong
things
the the billionaires the great creatives
the people of great impact the people
who live beautiful lives are very
intentional they're very deliberate
they're very conscious so for 20 minutes
you write in a journal
you can visualize you can pray you can
meditate you can simply
contemplate
how you're going to live your day what
you want to stand for during the day for
example and then the final pocket of the
20 20 20 formula is all about grow and
that's where you you you just read from
a biography or a business book or a
philosophy book or a watch marietv well
especially watching tv yeah of course
that's the game changer isn't it and so
that's 20 minutes of growing because i
think we're most alive when we are
growing yes and um i believe the leader
who learns the most wins so that's in a
nutshell the 20 20 20 for me it is so
powerful to be in the business of doing
hard things what makes a leader what a
what's an entrepreneur it's someone who
literally
understands that you get paid to find
solutions to difficult things
in your life as a human being outside of
business
choose difficult things choose the
longer run choose the harder workout
read the difficult book have the hard
conversation
vote for the challenging project that no
one else in your industry will do
and that is a great way
to develop build willpower because as
you
move through the project towards
completion
it draws hidden forces and strengths
that you did not know you had
out to see the light of day and you get
to know how powerful you are i would say
an addiction a distraction is the death
of your creative production wow when it
comes to productivity
in the everyday hair manifesto there is
a revolutionary rule called the five
great hours rule
so you don't need to work for seven
hours a day i do not subscribe to hustle
and grind i don't work for more than a
few hours a day
i take
i work four hours every week i take four
months plus off every single year how i
do it is in the book including the
weekly design system
when i work i i'm away from distraction
there's a difference between real work
and that's right there's a difference
between real work and fake work
let us not confuse busy
with productivity let us not confuse
movement with impact so i think that's
really important and we can get into the
menlo park and the type of total focus
structures but you talked about family
yet
and
i believe the greatest gift we can give
another human being is the gift of our
presence
and if you look at the greatest heroes
and the greatest leaders they had an
ability
to be there
and
and the very fact you said it means you
do practice it and i can tell everyone
watching right now you have so much
presence and i'm not talking about
charisma which you have you're talking
about you are here
in a world where a lot of people are
cyber zombies and
you know
just not present so i think you can
change the world and live a world-class
life
or you can play with your phone all day
you can't do both and we could get into
the science of
emotional residue every single time you
check a notification every single time
you like something serve
it's the formula for happiness find a
cause that's larger than yourself and
donate the remainder of your life to it
serve
meet someone on the street try to make
them
leave them better than you found them
serve in your business life be a servant
leader servant hero ask yourself how can
i deliver magic and value to them
serve serve your family if you have
children grow your children develop your
children inspire your children your
significant other help that person
become the person that they're meant to
be serve the world in your own unique
way
that would be my advice
to you if i were dying i want to remind
people of who they truly are and when
they see nelson mandela or
oprah winfrey
they say
they did it
but legendary is simply a testimony to
ordinary people
who thought differently felt differently
and did different things
and there by
became who they were and if they can do
it
i can do it
if i go all in i want to get that that
message out even more if you give
yourself that one hour that i called the
victory hour free from distraction free
from interruption what you're doing is
you are building an inner core of
heroism and
undefeatability so that six o'clock you
feel fundamentally different your
neurobiology has been is on fire
your metabolic rate is higher you know
this you've actually connected with your
values if you've taken some time to
journal you you've connected with your
mountaintop you're grounded in what's
most important you've practiced some
calm and you've even done some learning
you're far more intentional stronger and
energetic and creative by six o'clock
then you're going into our messy world
where there's confusion and you face
challenges and you know but you're not
busy being busy you're monomaniacally
focused on the few things that will get
you to your mount everest there's a line
in the book which it comes from the
spartan warrior credo sweat more in
trading and you'll sweat more in
training and you'll bleed less in war
yes
victories are one
before you even step onto the field you
look at kobe bryant you know for example
or shaq or lebron or federer or serena
these people
made the moves they made that won them
the championship not because of what
they did on the championship court
it was their sweaty disciplined practice
at 5 00 am while the rest of the world
was not watching that allowed them to
automate
world-class in times of pressure
so
you're right 5am getting up at 5am
joining the 5am club giving yourself
that time the quietude when it's the
time of least distraction to do the work
we're talking about will revolutionize
any human life that's why i say it's the
mother of all habits that's why i'm so
passionate about it when i was growing
up my father who's just celebrated his
83rd birthday and he's one of the great
heroes of my life and when i was growing
up marie he shared something from
rabindranath to gord the bengali poet
that i've never forgotten
and my dad used to say son when you were
born you cried while the world rejoiced
he said robin live your life in such a
way that when you die the world cries
while you rejoice
and what i mean by that is no matter how
long we get to live like right now
everyone on the planet in 100 years
we're going to be dust total dust powder
and and so all the things that we think
are so important the accolades applies
the number of likes followers except you
know bikini picks or wearing the right
watch
none of that matters and i believe only
two things matter on the last hour for
our last day number one who did you
become
were you good
were you authentic
did you walk towards your fears and as
messy and bloody as it was walk through
them so you wear your scar tissue with
pride as you go out and bring your gifts
and genius to the world
as you stand for something higher in a
world of
with a lot of people suffering from
victimitis excusitis
as you bring your glory to your days
you're going to threaten people
i was in the barcelona picasso museum in
the bourne district and there was a
a quote on the wall in the picasso
museum that said people were terrified
by the genius of picasso
so the more you shine the more you're
going to attract shadows and darkness
wow
so here's what i would say i i've
actually worked out in my journal what i
call the troll
deconstruction wow is this the journal
that got stolen it's not the one that
got stolen so i still have it okay um
but that's why journaling's so powerful
because you can actually deconstruct and
figure things these things out sure okay
so here's what i would say the people
who are attacking you critics and cynics
are frustrated dreamers
when they were kid they were kids they
were full of awe and wonder because
that's our natural state
but something happened to them as they
moved out in the world and pursued their
dreams and ambitions that caused them to
con contract
and so now there are these armchair
critics that see lewis house doing
amazing things well you actually model
possibility for them the possibility
that exists within their mindsets heart
sets health set and soul set and it's
much easier for them to try to tear you
down than lift themselves up and get in
the game themselves
so that would be the first thing i'd say
second the second thing i'd say
is
everything in life you know
mr reilly one of the characters
towards the end of the 5 a.m club gets
into the philosophy behind greatness and
genius and world-class and legendary
on a franchot south africa vineyard and
he writes a series of letters that are
transformational for the other
characters
and one of the things he talks about is
trusting your art so i think these
people who are trying to tear you down
are actually your spiritual friends
how so well because they are causing you
to trust yourself more
i mean they're they are strengthening
your resolve to pursue your mighty
mission they are helping you they are
helping they are touching the wounds
within you and the
insecurities and we have a choice we can
we can blame which is losing your power
or we can say how can i use what they're
activating with within me
to heal these wounds grow stronger
and and build the relationship with my
primal genius even more i've talked to
so many people who say well you know i
got to i must become an expert before i
go out there and launch my business i
must become an expert before i go out
there and
whatever write that book create that
movie launch that movement
well
every amateur every professional was
once an amateur
and every master was once a beginner
right
and so please remember there will never
be a better time to step into
the performance and the human being
you've always wanted to be
than today
one of the greatest pitfalls i've seen
in having worked with so many people
over a quarter of a century teaching
leadership and elite performance
is that people postpone
their greatness and their eminence to
some distant time in the future when
they're going to have more time and the
stars will align and that is one of the
greatest mistakes that you could
possibly make we don't know what
tomorrow's going to bring
right and you do not want to be one of
those people who
on the last day of their lives they were
full of regret because they couldn't
they didn't do what they knew they could
have done
you are worthy everything there are no
extra people on the planet today every
single one of us
is born into a unique genius only you
have the fingerprints you have only you
have the characteristics you have only
you have the strengths that you have you
are so unique on a planet of how many
billions of people
the the thing that happens is we lose
our confidence as we get hurt and
disappointed by life and a lot of us
what we do is we shut down and we
contract and we protect our once tender
open hearts versus going out into the
arena and sharing our gifts in full
blazing glory please do not think you
are unworthy
of
domain dominance please don't think
you're unworthy of because of
becoming best in the world at what you
do if you sacrifice train learn work
with mentors find the right talent hub
and then optimize your craft every
single day until you reach best in the
world a lot of talk these days about
legacy you know work in a way that
leaves a legacy
uh 22 years ago i wrote a book called
who will cry when you die and it was all
about legacy and back then i was
34 years old long time ago
and i used to talk so much about legacy
you know live in a way that
you live in the hearts that you leave
behind that's really the answer
now
with a little griz white grizzle
uh
i don't think legacy matters i think
legacy is like trying to get your name
on a hospital wing or a monument built
after you i think it's a pursuit of the
ego
the real key is not to worry much about
how you'll be remembered but the real
key i suggest to you with great love and
respect is living fully and greatly
while you are alive
because once you're dead you're dead
you're just a pile of dust
what did
the benevolent and great roman general
and warrior and emperor
marcus aurelius say
alexander the great was buried next to
his stable boy
we don't matter after we've
we're gone
so
i don't think you should i think it's
such a myth to be concerned about legacy
if you're trying to live a world-class
life
worry about being world class while
you're alive be concerned with
optimizing your craft while you have a
beating heart
be concerned with caring for the
brothers and sisters on this little
planet and standing for honesty honor
grace and love
leave every person you meet better than
you found them
and the irony is if you do that you will
leave a legacy even though it's not your
intention we're brothers and sisters on
a little planet
that person
that homeless person was someone's
dreams at a time
the
person in the restaurant or the hotel
who it's very easy if we're numbed out
and not awake
i'm not someone's father or mother
and
when i look at most people on the planet
it's no judgment i just
i see people who are they're in scarcity
versus generosity i see so many people
saying you know when i was a kid i had
all this creativity i don't know where
it happened you see it every day
you have all these people i want to
build a business oh i i oh i guess i ca
it's psychology of can't versus
mentality of possibility i see people
in pain i see people
playing victim i mean wouldn't you agree
most people on the planet at some
foreign form or another whether it's
with their creativity or their
prosperity or their personal lives
they're they're stuck in victimhood i
think there's just an opportunity for
people when they bring their full
presence and their heart to their work
you will be seen now given the landscape
as extraordinary
in the 5am club i call it a gca a
gargantuan competitive advantage it has
never been it has never been so
uncrowded at world class because so few
people are doing the fundamentals of
world class
so few people literally sit down in in
blocks of time create what i call a
tight bubble of total focus and do real
work versus fake work everybody should
have core values what is what are some
of your most deeply cherished core
values
service above self
in other words contribution impact
service
number two
family
i mean
if i could be a tenth of the human being
my two children are i'd be a
i'd be
i'd be amazing
family you know
i've worked very hard but i've
really
worked hard on my family too even trying
to be a great son you know great brother
all those things because we all know to
get to the last day of your last
of your life and say i made a lot of
money and i got a lot of likes and i
sold a lot of books and i impact a lot
of people
and your own family never got to know
you that's heartbreak
third value i'm an ask that the french
word lover of beauty
you know that's why you know that's why
i love los angeles like we were coming
over here and it's like
there's flowers you know it's whatever
time of the year is the flowers
everywhere you know
um so i love beauty and art and food and
people and sunsets and that's why i love
rome so much now that fourth value would
be um vitality
you know i really do believe that
the the one of the keys to legendary is
longevity i mean i want to live until
177 i want to you know
right i mean i'm biohacking and i'm
resting and i'm doing the two massage
protocol and everything possible
so i can be rocking my craft and serving
as many people as possible when i'm into
you know i mean one of the things i'd
say is you never want to let an old
person anywhere near the inside of your
body right
because and we could get into
epigenetics and the fact that we have a
chronological age and a biological age
but vitality is important and then i
think the
final core value is lifestyle
you know we can serve the world and
that's very important i know to both of
us
but i want it's life is ultimately a
really short ride
and so i want to really be around only
people
i mean i am focused i only want people
in my orbit that bring me joy or fuel my
joy
i only want to do the pursuits in my
business and career and life that bring
me joy
and i only go to places where i feel joy
i would say pleasing
comes from fear
and a lack of
standing in your true power
there's a distinction i make in the 5
a.m club between fake power
big office for example lots of money
jets
titles that's fake power
true power is
mother teresa mahatma gandhi he died
with under 10 possessions that's true
power he he did not get his power from
who he was in the world and by pleasing
people he got his power by intimacy with
his highest nature that's true power so
what's the difference between pleasing
and service pleasing comes from
scarcity and fear
self-loathing and insecurity
if they don't like me
then i'm not enough
well you know any great genius any the
great women and men of the world
stood alone even if they were an army of
one galileo coco chanel catherine graham
shakespeare
john michelle basquiat if you look at
the great producers of the planet they
were ridiculed before they were revered
you can change the world or you can be
liked by everyone you don't get to do
both
so service comes from here's my vision
maybe it's the internet maybe it's apple
maybe it's you know writing a book or a
movie here's my vision
and even if the world laughs at me
i am so strong
in my vision to serve
to disrupt the field to bring on value
and to live my truth that even if they
shoot me and take a bullet
i will continue at all costs that is a
titan that's a legend
but a lot of us have not done the inner
excavation and that's why i go back to
the four interior empires that's why the
five am club five to six the victory
hour doing the protocols that i teach in
the book is transformational because the
doorway to success doesn't open outward
if you get it inward and build that core
that warrior
meets poet self you go out in the world
you're powerful get your morning routine
right
one of the key themes in the 5m club is
as you start your morning so you
construct and build your day
the spartan warriors said it amazingly
they said sweat more in training and
you'll bleed less in war
so you look at most people and they
begin their day like a five alarm fire
you know they start checking their email
they start you know hitting the ground
running and so what the 5m club method
is really all about is the 20 20 20
formula that i've that has worked
amazing results with the the titans and
the a players and the billionaires and
the sport superstars that i've worked
with and it's simply
the first 20 minutes of your day's
intense exercise and we can get into why
that's important in terms of dopamine
and reducing cortisol and serotonin and
norepinephrine and then after that the
second 20 minute pocket
which we can get into is all about
reflection which is where
it's journaling and it's meditation and
it's visualization and you can do some
affirmations and guess what you could
just sit there in solitude and think i
mean the great heroes of the world were
more thoughtful
than ordinary people i smile because
after this interview i go dark for a
long time as well and i'm in rome which
is one of my favorite places in rome and
i travel to other places
in the 5am club there's a model that i
think is
profound because you're right we live in
a world that evangelizes non-stop hustle
it's all about the hustle if if you're
not scheduled 24 7 then you're a loser
and you're not doing something right
what i believe in the research actually
bears this out the elite performers
don't operate as marathoners it's more
like a sprint the energy project for
example has done some wonderful work in
this field
and so i have
in the model is basically hec your high
excellence cycle in your deep recovery
cycle in other words there are periods
through the day where you bring on
intense fire intense creativity and then
you pull back and recover so one of the
rituals in the book is the the 6010
method you work for 60 minutes it's full
on fire sprint 10 minutes you recover
you drink a cup of tea you meditate you
listen to music then you come back with
an alarm clock in front of you another
60 minutes of profound work creative
work sweaty work and then another 10
minutes of recovery and then you do that
during the week you take two days off or
three days off to refuel and then as you
probably do as well you take you know a
month off or two weeks off and so what
i'm trying to suggest um
is
if you're if all you're doing
is being an elite performer
then you're going to actually deplete
the very assets that allow you to own
your game and play the long game in the
book there's five assets of genius it's
not just you know your talent i believe
it's your mental focus your physical
energy your personal willpower your
original talent and your daily time and
so smart creative people and the most
productive people they work really hard
and then they rest without guilt and
they recover and they have fun i mean
the japanese novelist haruki murukami
says when i'm not writing and enjoying
life my ids are incubating and i'm
writing my next book clean out your
ecosystem we all have an ecosystem that
could be your friends it could be the
influencers you follow on social media
it could be the places you work it could
be your home
it could be your city it could be your
street we all have an environment and
your environment profoundly shapes your
energy your creativity your performance
and the way you live your life so you
want to upgrade to your next level of
world class you want to remove any form
of toxicity or low energy just
be the benchmark or the the meter is
basically what things bring you joy
versus what things decrease your
positivity and move towards the
activities and the people and the places
and the spaces that fill you with joy
this year if you really want to have
revolutions of uh increased performance
productivity and happiness there's
actually a piece of research that just
came out
and there was a dummy phone not even a
real phone but the very physical
presence of a phone that wasn't even
real reduce people's cognitive ability
in other words the very presence of a
phone makes us dumber i know this sounds
simple but it's so powerful
so many people say yes when this happens
i will do this
when i have more time i'll write the
book
when i make more money i'll invest in my
growth
when i get the promotion i'll take the
travel
no one knows what tomorrow brings no one
knows what tomorrow brings no one knows
what tomorrow brings keep on asking
yourself if i don't do this now
how will i feel later
so don't wait
i'm not saying be foolish
you want to definitely not make ill
considered choices
and at the same time do not wait you
know the the pathway to world class is
hard i think suffering's got a bad rap i
think difficulty you look at any you
know great athlete for example they
understand that
challenge difficulty grit persistence
wiring in new habits morning rituals
evening routines are the price of
admission for world class and so let's
go to the research again university
college london says it takes 66 days of
practice to wire in a new habit
the in other words
the gift of genius is not genius the
gift of genius is actually
neuroplasticity
in other words we have a brain that can
grow it's sort of plastic it's malleable
the good news is that's not just for
kanye and beyonce and federer and oprah
and
phil knight every one of us has that
capability in our brain to build genius
so what i'm suggesting is anyone who
wants to get up early so they get an
extra hour and they can do the things
that we're talking about practice it for
66 days until you will reach what
researchers call
a state of automaticity where it
actually gets easier to get up at 5 00
a.m than not to get up at 5 a.m and so
in the book one of the brain tattoos is
all change is hard at first and it's
messy in the middle and it's gorgeous at
the end yes and everything marie that we
once found difficult one that we now
find easy we once found difficult we do
have the ability to wire in new habits
and joining the 5am club is is simply
the best habit anyone can wire in to
lead to an upward spiral of success for
greater productivity better health more
peace of mind more happiness and living
a much more high impact life jim carrey
said i wish everyone could be rich and
famous to realize there's no joy in that
to paraphrase his words yes yes and you
know i i
look i i've seen the best and the best
i've had richard branson on my on my
faculty steve wozniak shaquille o'neal
i've i've worked with
real superstars
and um
a lot of them are just really unhappy
people i'm not saying the ones i
mentioned but a lot of them are really
unhappy people and they'll show you
their smiley face but deep inside
they're going i'm worth you know 3
billion and i've got jets and i've got
multiple residences
but there's there's got to be more and
so how i would urge people to embrace
the message of
being a forceful servant for people is
first of all if you're an entrepreneur
you have a lot of entrepreneurs who
follow you there's no better way than
standing for generosity if you want to
own your domain
you know what made apple apple first
trillion dollar company was steve jobs
wasn't worried about the cash he was
worried about the craft
someone came to one of my events and
said you know robin you mentioned steve
jobs i saw him six weeks before he died
i went into his den
as he was dying
and he said i think was just before the
release of the iphone and it was like um
you know that little thing we were
working on
he had a mono maniacal obsession
bordering on a possession to birth
beauty into the world that would elevate
the lives of his customers that's
generosity not scarcity
so it's great for business secondly if
you want real joy
it doesn't come from getting
and a lot of the book is about how you
materialize
empires in the world but the end of the
book when mr riley the billionaire we
can talk about the story he's on that
franchot vineyard and he shares his 11
letters
and he explains he uses a word called
the magic
and if you want to inhabit the magic
i've done it at parts of my life i don't
know if you have but i've experienced
bliss
and then it comes in a ghost
but bliss has never come to me from
getting
bliss and joy and what me mihai chick
sent me high who coined the term flow
from university of chicago
when we are literally in that moment
when we're in our magic that comes from
giving
it comes from being in the moment when
you're writing that book going how can i
be an instrument of service and bring on
my craft
giving like helping someone on the
street doing something for your you know
i'm really into philanthropy these days
that's my joy so that's how i would urge
people like if if you want real empires
if you want real happiness you want real
bliss you want to elevate your immune
system look there's lots of science
just go out in the world and give as
much value as you possible and radiate
possibility and amazing things will
unfold in your life once you understand
that life is short once you understand
that
living your life to please other people
while betraying your own ethical
ambitions is a waste of time and once
you remember that tomorrow could be the
end
hopefully it won't be and i'm sure it
won't be
but no one knows when we check out no
one knows when our last day will be
and it is a false assumption that we all
will all get to live into our 90s
and once you really build intimacy like
emotional intimacy not only intellectual
emotional intimacy with the fact that
this could be
one of your final days
then it's not a depressing thing it
becomes an inspirational thing you start
to live by your own
drum beat you start to listen to your
own authentic voice you start to do be
braver start to be a little more loving
you start to be more kinder you start to
do bolder things you start to seize
opportunities because you're not in
limbic hijack over
failing which is one of the big reasons
why we don't take great steps i think a
bad day for the ego is a great day for
the soul
and you know you were talking about
people who say well maybe you know maybe
i don't want to get up at 5 a.m it's not
for me and here's
why i can't do it and one thing i've
realized is
we we become victims when we recite our
excuses and we recite them so many times
we actually believe they are true
and i think you can cling to your
excuses or you can go out there and have
an impact and live a fulfilling life and
be highly creative and and enjoy the
magic life but you don't get to do both
and so you're right no one's no one's
saying you know burn yourself out and
hurt yourself or anything like that i
think one there's a whole chapter in the
5am club on the essentialness of rest i
believe that elite performance without
deep recovery leads to depletion of all
your assets of genius so i think
it's it's self-awareness to know when
should you rest when should you pull
back when should you give up from a
project or when you should just continue
past your limits so you can find new
horizons and that's about getting to
know yourself
but i think
growth comes from stretching ourselves i
used to be a litigation lawyer so i come
from very humble beginnings i was
blessed with
incredible parents but i sure didn't
grow up with a silver spoon in my mouth
and you know i louis i've experienced
what life is like at the top of the
mountain but i've also been in the
valley of darkness and
if you were to deconstruct the word
passion the root is suffering really and
suffering makes great leaders suffering
makes the mandelas suffering makes the
oprahs
um and i think a great life richly lived
has lots of the good as well as the
challenge yeah in your career have you
noticed that when you've taken that path
towards growth you're like oh my
goodness look at all i can accomplish
now yeah absolutely i think a bad day
for the ego is a great day for the soul
and you know you were talking about
people who say well maybe you know maybe
i don't want to get up at 5 a.m it's not
for me and here's why i can't do it and
one thing i've realized is
we we become victims when we recite our
excuses and we recite them so many times
we actually believe they are true
and i think you can cling to your
excuses or you can go out there and have
an impact and live a fulfilling life and
be highly creative and and enjoy the
magic life but you don't get to do both
i have journaled to say that i do
journal would be a lie
you're going to love journaling like i i
do it almost every day
i had um i had a show this morning and
then i had to set my intentions for you
and all your global followers or viewers
and so i went back to my hotel room i
took a cold shower
you know i've been fasting a lot so we
can get into fasting because i fasted as
i wrote the
5n collab and that helped massively and
then i pulled out my journal and i sat
on my terrace
and i literally started writing about my
intentions for impact theory
and so how do you how do you move
through pain you journal
um if you're going through a heartbreak
i mean we've all experienced heartbreak
what we do is often we repress it
because we're not given the tools to
process through it you lose a business
people repress it
someone has a divorce or an illness
oh
mindset
reframe it psychology you're swallowing
pain you're swallowing sadness you're
swallowing anger we're built to feel
right so
writing in a journal just getting it out
there's actually something in the 5m
club called the journaling
deconstruction because it's not just
processing through pain but to answer
your question that trauma of heart set
you write in a journal you get it out of
your system guess what you don't bring
passive aggressive into the workplace
you don't bring sadness or low vibe into
the workplace
you're full of your true self in terms
of your heart set which is gratitude
love appreciation you know what that
does for a business you know what that
does for a human life so if you're going
through a painful time write that out
almost every day i write gratitude but i
love great restaurants and so i'll take
the business card and the next morning i
pull out my little glue stick and i glue
the business card into my journal
and i relive the experience oh i had
dinner with so and so here's what i
learned i deconstruct it with better
awareness
we'll make better choices
better daily choices better daily
results imagine journaling like this
every single day you're going to have
such a cute awareness about when you're
at your best what the great ones do how
to live a life what you want to stand
for what your core values are you walk
out in the world and you're just
radiating possibility in a world where
people are addicted to distraction and
numbed out why don't they teach us
before interior empires why don't they
teach us
you said something very powerful
why don't they teach us how to work
through wounds you don't get invited to
a birthday party in fifth grade there is
a wound there you lose a love when
you're 16.
there is a wound there you start a
business when you're 22
there is trauma there and i think that
is in many ways the missing link in
leadership and personal mastery and
that's really you know i'm passionate
about the 5am club because i get into
that in in the book
and i worked four years on the book but
it's really 22 years of my my
learnings and teaching in the book and
that is a missing link because
everyone's talking about psychology and
people are talking about habits and i'll
answer your question of course
but what about dealing with trauma you
know carl jung said we all have this
shadow side i mean we all have this well
of repressed pain and anyone who's
listening who goes well that's not me
it's subconscious so a lot unless you've
done the work you don't even know about
it but it's that pain and self-loathing
and self-hatred
in the 5-m club i say you know we have a
magic inside of us the saints call it
the light or god or nature or
luminosity
and what happens is when you do the work
to
release your toxic beliefs and move
through your pain and how do you do it
you just feel it
and as you feel through all the toxicity
and the hurt and the wounding and the
disappointment that's called a human
journey
what is left as you release it
you access your light you access your
primal genius
you access creativity you're productive
because you don't have all this
emotional baggage you're carrying
through the day
you've you know
i believe that the real artist the real
key to success is joy and inner peace
like that's why all the a lot of the
billionaires they have all the things
and they're not happy
you
our nature is joy peace
bliss
love
and when you release that trauma
it just shows up because that's who we
truly are i think one of the greatest of
all spiritual pursuits is learning how
to let go
learning how to let go of people who
hurt you learning how to let go of
events that have disappointed you it is
not until you really get good at letting
go that you can
advance into your bullish and brighter
future and how do you let go well you
can journal about it you can make a
conscious intention to just let go or
maybe you let go by philosophical
understanding understanding that the
people who might have hurt you were
doing the best that they could do based
on where they are at in their own
evolution and that people who are
hurting hurt other people
or maybe you can let go by prayer or
auto suggestion or meditation or
visualization so the first philosophical
point is let go there's a lot of
emerging science saying here's the
reality and anyone who wants to dismiss
it is denying science which is
planet earth is a tiny planet in a
galaxy of trillions of planets
um my friend deepak chopra was on my
stage at one of my events a few months
ago he's a lovely man he just radiates
goodness
and um he took us on a tour to force
about cosmology and he's been a pioneer
for so many years and he confirmed the
science which is we are all part of an
energy source whatever you want to call
it god uh nature life and you're
absolutely right jay your intentions are
creative so we could come at it from a
cosmo cosmological point of view when
you say here's who i want to be you know
this morning in my journaling i'm going
to meet jay
i'm so delighted and blessed that he's
invited me on his show because he
influences so many people how may i
serve
that intention
hopefully is creative so we're very
powerful
i'll come at it another way which is
epigenetics
epigenetics as you know
stands for the emerging field of science
which is you are not your genome the old
school said your dna what you get from
mom and dad that's your destiny we're
now realizing that epigenetics means
our environment our daily rituals like
getting up at 5 am our thoughts
what we eat our peer group etc
literally affects the up regulation or
down regulation of our genome
what does that mean it means if you
believe in yourself if you do the work
in the journaling if you get up at 5 00
a.m and do that victory hour and go
through the 20 20 20 formula you
literally are recalibrating who you will
become out in the world so you're
absolutely right then you start
channeling your intentions
and you start stepping into your power
like we are awesomely powerful beings
most of us have blocked our our intimacy
with our true power if you build the
business if you get the jet if you get
the money if you get the cars if you get
the beautiful spouse then you're going
to be happy
what i believe and there's a model in
the 5am club that i think is a very
disruptive model but it's a
transformational model and it's called
the four interior empires and it's not
just mindset it's mindset heart set
health set and soul set and we can talk
about it if you like but i worked on
those four interior empires when i was a
very unhappy litigation lawyer like i'd
made money i was successful i had two
law degrees and yet i wake up every
morning time and i'd go into the
bathroom mirror and i'd look at myself
and i was a completely empty person
and nothing
is more expensive than losing your joy
and your peace of mind
and so what i did was i started working
on myself you know i worked on my
mindset and i read all the books and i
went to the courses but that's only your
psychology and i think that's one of the
missing links in our field which is
everyone's talking about mindset but
mindset is just your belief system it's
just your psychologies it's very
important but that's 25 of the personal
mastery equation
i believe the second piece is your heart
set and i worked on that purifying your
heart that's your emotionality not just
your psychology you're never going to
make history
dominate your domain and hand craft a
world-class life if you've got a great
psychology but you're carrying the pain
and sadness disappointment and trauma of
the past
so i worked on my heart step that's only
the second interior empire the third
interior empire your health set don't
die if you want to change the world like
dead people don't change the world
so health set
biohacking there's a whole chapter on
recovery and the essentialness of sleep
so really getting your health set right
but
there's a fourth interior empire that i
worked on
that allowed me to go out in the world
and and pursue my my magic
and
it's a little dangerous for me to share
because i know how many business people
you know follow you and how many
entrepreneurs but i'm going to share it
because it's my truth so it's not just
mindset and it's not just heart set it's
not just health that set its soul set
and soul set has nothing to do with
religion soul set is about working on
your character
so you re-access your nobility and your
bravery and your authenticity
and your decency
and you find a cause that's larger than
your life
so when you go out in the world every
single morning
people might ridicule you because every
genius is ridiculed before they're
revered people might throw stones at you
but you use them to build monuments of
mastery people might not mis understand
you because any disruptor is going to be
misunderstood and even you're if you're
an army of one a galileo or a
steve jobs or how phil knight
you continue at all costs so those four
interior empires that i go into detail
and in the book give you a fiery inner
core of warriorship and leadership that
allow you to go out in the world and do
amazing things but it all starts with
who you are because you'll never rise
any higher than what's going on within
you the research as i mentioned at
university college of london says it
takes 66 days for any human being to
wire any in a habit and we all have a
gift called neuroplasticity so we all
can do it and then the model i i share
in the book is called the habit
installation protocol and basically it's
22 days called installation excuse me
called destruction
to get up early you've got to destroy
your old neural patterns and emotional
signatures of getting up later
that doesn't happen in an instant all
change is hard at first messy in the
middle gorgeous at the end so that first
destruction phase is 22 days there's
nothing wrong society says it's hard so
it's bad i'm suggesting it's hard so
it's good that's what real change is as
you with that awareness you can stay
with it and get into the second phase
which is
installation
and that's like a house renovation which
is messy and that's why change is messy
in the middle
your old pathways and ways of being are
falling apart but you know this because
i sense you have a very deep grounding
in that middle part you have to
in some ways let go of who you were it's
called a dark night of the soul
so for 22 days it's it's messy in the
middle because you're letting go of who
you were that's not easy and that's why
habit installation you need to have some
bravery but that's only 22 days stay
with it because then you get to the
third phase which is implementation so
destruction integration
implementation well now we're on the
short roads and the neuroplasticity has
kicked in and
the researchers call it automaticity you
will every human being can get to a
place 66 days later approximately where
it actually gets easier to get up at 5am
than to stay in the bed and the point is
it's called automaticity and that's it
you know
we all have that ability we just need to
stay with that three-stage process for
66 days yeah
the great ones are all misfits and
they're all
weird
i mean
the very nature of being a disrupter and
a leader means you're not a follower
and if you're not a follower then you're
not buying the kool-aid that society
sells you
if you're not a follower you're not like
this all the time looking for likes
if if you're not a follower you dress
the way you want to dress if people
criticize you yeah they criticize all
the great ones
critics are nothing more than dreamers
who got scared and never got off their
chairs and got back in the game so
you've got to be willing to be to 5 a.m
weird who does that why not sleep
leaders have to be willing not to be
followers most people in the room no
that's not everyone in the room has been
traumatized no one talks about this oh
this is a business event you're talking
about trauma
everyone in this room has experienced
trauma at some level or another
to varying degrees
sometimes it wasn't being invited to
someone's party trauma
right
sometimes it was sexual abuse trauma
and so what happens is this is so
important i can spend the whole day on
this but
the human tendency and the cultural
seduction is don't feel the pain of the
trauma everyone know what i'm talking
about around my out on the jagged edges
don't feel the trauma don't feel the
disappointment you got heartbroken don't
go into it
only seek pleasure
only be happy happy happy
put on the happy face watch the happy tv
shows
seek pleasure
and
what we do is we actually flee from
feeling because of the trauma
and we start to live in our heads and we
numb out our body and we don't feel
but to be human is to feel
to be a great leader is to feel
if you look at the greatest empire
builders economically zuckerberg musk
steve jobs great example
[Music]
he felt deeply
you know he lived in a pretty simple
house
even when he was a multi-billionaire
simple house
he wasn't a he was only about a few
things he was about family he was about
you know what he said i love this
because i'm a purist
i built my build my life around just a
few things
he said my favorite things in life
books and sushi
isn't that beautiful
and he he was an artist
he was an artist
and so
mindset without heart set so we we
experience trauma and then we block it
out repress it and then we lose our
emotional game which is mission critical
to world class you've got to love your
clients you've got to love the beauty of
creating gorgeous products
you've got to want to serve it doesn't
happen in the head
oh you know
service to your clients to the
marketplace happens in your heart
you
the desire to lead a world-class life
happens
emotionally
and that's how you battle proof yourself
against volatility it's not an
intellectual game it's a visceral game
it's in your dna
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome for even more robin
sharma motivation check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there when we are kids we want we want
to be astronauts we want to be
billionaires we want to be history
makers
we want to do all our dreams
and then and
we stand in awe and wonder